hello everyone one of the blockchain
initiatives within hyperledger is
hyperledger fabric it utilizes smart
contracts has a ledger and functions as
a means of for participants to manage
their transactions just like other
blockchain technologies
the fact that hypeology fabric is
private and permission sets it apart
from all of the blockchain platforms so
here i am with a new video by simply
learn on hyperledger fabric to give you
a better insight of hyperledger fabric
along with its concept
but before proceeding with the video
please do hit the like button and
subscribe to our youtube channel to
never miss an update from simply learn
so let's get started with the video
first let's have a look at the topics
that we are going to cover in this video
first we will have an understanding of
what hyperledger fabric is
following that we will have a look at
some of the benefits of hyperledger
fabric
after that we will understand the
working of hyperledger fabric
following that we will explore the
transaction flow of hyperledger fabric
and at the end we will have a look at
some of the industry use cases of
hyperledger fabric
so let's start with what is hyperledger
fabric
now the linux foundation launched
hyperledger fabric in 2015 as an open
source permission blockchain technology
now it is a general purpose modular
framework that provides distinctive
identity management and access control
features as a result it is appropriate
for a range of business applications
including trade finance loyalty and
reward programs track and trace of
supply chains and clearing and
settlement of financial ad so
technically speaking it enables
plug-and-play compatibility for
components like membership services and
consensus so now that we have the
understanding of hyperledger fabric
let's have a look at some of its
benefits to better understand its
functionality
so first is open source
the linux foundation is the host of the
open source hyperledger fabric
technology which is a blockchain
framework the developer community is
vibrant and expanding
second is permission
fabric network which means that the
identities of every individual
who participates are known and verified
this advantage is especially beneficial
in sectors like healthcare supply chain
management
finance and insurance where data cannot
be accessible to unidentified parties
for instance to protect consumer privacy
an insurance provider on an hyperledger
fabric blockchain network can share
customer claim data with authorized
parties third is
governance and access control
fabric networks are made up of channels
which are private subnets of
communication between two or more
particular network members
through these channels network users can
conduct confidential and private
business
every transaction on the blockchain
network takes place on a channel where
each person involved must be verified
and given permission to conduct business
this adds an extra degree of access
control and is particularly helpful when
members want to restrict how much
information is made public for instance
when rivals are on the same network
fourth is performance
because of its consensus mechanism
hyperledger fabric can support his high
transaction throughput for enterprise
grade use cases fabric is a permission
blockchain system therefore it does not
have to deal with byzantine fault
tolerance which might result in slower
network transaction validation
performance
so now let's move on and have a look at
the working of fabric network
so an open tested enterprise way
distributed ledger platform is
hyperledger fabric it proposes unique
privacy control so that only the
information you want to share
is shared with the permitted network
users
the business processes you want to
automate are documented in smart
contracts with self-executing clauses
between the parties that are written in
lines of code the code and the
agreements contained therein exist
across the distributed decentralized
blockchain network
these transactions are retraceable and
irreversible organizations can trust one
another due to this ability to quickly
make better judgments organizations can
save time money and risk
so now that we know the working of
hyperledger fabric let's understand its
transaction flow
so first when a client application sends
a transaction proposal to peers in each
organization for approval the
transaction flow starts
second the peers confirm the identity
and legitimacy of the submitting client
to submit the transaction after that
they simulate the result of the proposed
transaction
and if they match what was anticipated
they send the customer an endorsement
signature
third once it has the required number of
endorsements as specified in the
endorsement policy the client gathers
recommendation from peers and transmit
the transaction to the ordering service
and lastly in order to comply with the
endorsement policy the ordering service
verifies that a transaction has the
required number of endorsements
the accepted transaction are then
chronologically ordered bundled into
blocks and sent to peer within each
organization the ordering service sends
new blocks of transaction to peer nodes
who subsequently do a final validation
on the transactions in that block as
soon as this is finished the ledger
state is updated and the new block is
added
the fresh deals have been committed
now so that we have covered all the
necessary details regarding hyperledger
fabric let's have a look at some of the
industrial use cases of hyperledger
fabric
the first one is supply chains
now supply chains are vast dispersed
network of suppliers producers and
retailers by boosting the transparency
and traceability of transaction within
the network hyperledger fabric networks
can enhance supply chain procedures
companies who have access to the ledge
on a fabric network can see the same
unchangeable data in forcing
responsibility and lowering the
possibility of counterfeiting
then comes trading
now importers exporters banks shipping
companies and customer offices are just
a few of many institutions that must
collaborate in order for trade to take
place
now financially and trading consortiums
can simply build a blockchain network
using hyperledger fabric
where all the participants can conduct
business and handle trade related
documents electronically without the
need for a central trusted authority
in fact contrary to other processes
which require players to exchange trade
related documents back and forth
taking 5-10 days to complete next is
insurance
now the insurance sector loses billions
of dollars each year to fraud but using
hyperledger fabric insurance companies
can use transaction data stored on the
ledger to spot duplicate and fabricated
claims by leveraging smart contracts to
automate payment from the at paul party
back to the insurance company blockchain
can help speed up the processing of
multi-party suborgation claims so this
brings us to the end of this video well
this was all about hyperledger fabric if
you have any questions regarding this
video please feel free to ask them in
our comment section our team will reach
out to you as soon as possible hope you
enjoyed this video and learn something
new from it thank you and stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here